Qué significa la liebre en el ciclo
zodiacal y como esto repercute en la
cultura china
bueno Muchas gracias María Clara por la
invitación sí efectivamente la liebre es
un animal que estaba presente en la
cultura china desde hace milenios y que
representa normalmente prosperidad
representa Esperanza representa belleza
bondad es un animal que se se relaciona
mucho a lo femenino y por eso mientras
que para los chinos es genial tener
mujeres no como niñas que nazcan en años
de la liebre no no les parece tan
chévere tener hombres que nazcan en el
año de la liebre en cualquier caso la
liebre es un animal que reciben con
mucha esperanza no lo considera un
animal suave y que siempre va a traer
buena fortuna e incluso la liebre es un
animal que honran todos los años en
octubre en el festival de otoño cuando
porque creen que el conejo deja de o la
liebre vive en la luna y que siempre
está como haciéndole elixir de la vida
entonces es un animal presente año a año
en la tradición China y obviamente el
año de la liebre es muy bienvenido desde
ese lugar no se considera que es un de
esperanza y de luz y Qué diferencia hay
entre la liebre y el Tigre porque el año
que se acaba era precisamente el de este
animal hay una gran diferencia no
mientras el tigre es un animal masculino
Por decirlo de alguna manera fuertes a
gas Valiente y a pesar de que era de
agua Haz de cuenta que el agua del tigre
era como una torrente un maremoto que
que iba muy muy fuerte en cambio la
liebre es femenina y suave y el agua de
la liebre de este año es más como un
Manantial Es algo más tranquilo es decir
todo lo que el año pasado nos nos
sobrepasó este año va a ser más
tranquilo más calmado la liebre es ágil
para lograr Digamos como buenas ideas y
demás pero a la vez es más tranquila en
la forma como ASUME los retos Mientras
que el tigre era muy valiente muy
valeroso y muy rápido y eso a veces era
un problema también Mira y cómo funciona
el calendario lunisolar de China y
cuáles son sus diferencias respecto al
calendario gregoriano que se utiliza en
occidente
bueno básicamente el calendario chino
empezó a hacerse desde en la dinastía ya
hace cuatro mil años y observaba más los
ciclos de la luna que los ciclos del sol
sin dejar de observar los ciclos del sol
la evolución de este calendario hizo que
llegaran a lograr esa medida de 365 días
para un año y de veinticuatro horas para
un día más o menos 300 o 400 años antes
de que el calendario gregoriano saliera
adelante es un calendario entonces
basado para para explicar el año nuevo a
partir de la observación de la luna si
bien Se mira el sol para ver lo que es
un año los rituales y la comprensión de
de cómo cómo funcionan los ciclos de la
vida y de la tierra está dividida en 12
años y está basada básicamente en eso en
el ciclo lunar Por eso cada año es
distinto O sea la fecha no es la misma
porque el año nuevo se celebra en
segunda Luna nueva después del
equinoccio de después del solsticio de
invierno básicamente